each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
so today we're glad to have shelter from
UIUC to give us a talk on audio-visual
event detection Sheldon is a PhD
candidate and at the UIUC he got his
master's degree from Electrical
Engineering at the UC in 2007 and
bachelor degree from Ching hai
University in 2005 so we thought for the
bill thank you for coming in the morning
so today I talk about modeling audio and
visual cues for reward event detection
this is the topic i picked format for my
dissertation as an umbrella to to
include a couple of projects i got
involved over the years i also prepared
a couple of snapshot slides towards the
end just covering a couple of other
projects i was involved in that might be
interesting to this audience so
audio-visual event detection aims to
identify semantically defined events
that review human activities I agree
we'll all agree here that the wild
speech is the most informative
information source in audio stream and a
lot of the non-speech events also tell
you what's happening in the in your
environment for example on the acoustic
side if you have events like door slams
steps chair moving keygen going this
room they tell you something about
what's happening and in particular if we
hear a very loud yawn here at the very
first five minutes of the talk then
that's also something that tells you a
lot about the talk we also know there
for the video events it's also very
apparent that if you can figure out
what's happening in the video it it
makes uses to multiple applications like
like surveillance human-computer
action I'm supporting dependence and
well-being of Asian population video
annotation and multimedia retrieval in
general so as useful as these
applications are they are relatively
less studied that then speech
recognition it's also a shorter history
for these applications but they are
explored by different researchers before
for example many people worked on
detecting restricted highlight events
such as a gun shot in the street or
explosion in the movie or a goal
cheering detection in a sports game many
times people leveraged lower level
detectors for example a car detector a
flag detector an office detector for the
using these things for video event
detection and in particular people for
meeting room scenario like this people
would use a person tractor a laptop
detector phase detector and dog activity
estimator on the benefits hear that
hopefully these lower level detectors
are transferable between different tasks
but the drawback is that these are
usually ad hoc and need more annotation
for training so in this work we're
trying to see what could be a
generalizable and robust way to model
these skills for detection of reward
events by real-world events were meaning
events that come from data that that are
realistic and and there that are not
collected in a lab setting so my talk
will be roughly into three parts that
the major pieces are actually the first
two parts first I'll talk about a
classification detection of acoustic
events there's a lot of lessons learned
from the speech recognition community
that that actually i think this audience
will find a lot of the masses very
similar to what we using speech
recognition and they work so well
because they survived all these decades
of work in speech recognition community
so to detect and classify acoustic
events is a task
of significance according to the clear
evaluation that we were participating
the activity detection and description
is a key functionality of perceptually
aware interfaces working in
collaborative human communication
environments and these events usually
help described human activities so the
particular data set that we worked on
have over 12 events such as door slam
steps and chair moving key jingle they
are different they are difficult because
they we are talking about a set of
general events in a very realistic
environment we're not talking about a
particular very high light events like
explosion or something like that and
also the temporal constraint between
different events is much looser than in
speech there's no linguistic constraint
of course and usually they happen they
don't tend to happen following a
particular sequence the snr is low the
particular dataset and setup we use
actually was using 15 field microphone
so we haven't worked we haven't included
any being searched and I mean any array
my microphone array being searched in
this setup so the far field microphone
would have background noise and also
some background fire foreign talking
speech as a background we proposed
leverage and statistical models proven
effective in the speech recognition
literature in particular we use a tandem
connectionist hmm approach to combine
the sequence modeling capability of the
hmm with the context dependent
discriminative capability of an
artificial neural network so here we're
talking about one hmm for one particular
event so for 14 events will have 14 HMMs
and in a restoring stage or use a
support vector machine gaussian mixture
model super vector approach to use this
noise adaptive kernels tube at
approximately care of divergence between
feature distributions in different audio
segments we'll cover that in a while so
the way that we formulate acoustic event
detection is exactly the same way as in
speed
recognition in particular as a whole
word word sequence recognition so you
basically maximizing the Joint
Distribution between the observation and
the event sequence and for feature
representation while looking at sliding
window based sequences of local frame
based features so temporal segmentation
is is one of the major challenges for
this problem people have tried different
ways to address this for example you
could do super sliding window based
approaches basically detection by
classification people also come up with
ideas similar to a cascade of different
sliding windows try to improve accuracy
but from what we found and also from
what the results of the evaluation says
i'm using the Viterbi algorithm of HMMs
computer simultaneously optimal
segmentation classification of the audio
stream so so this is still the best
choice as we believe and we illustrate
this in evaluation in particular we
believe that the benefit is that the
noise in these individual frames will be
alleviated by by this learn the prior of
of preferring self transitions rather
than nownself transitions in a hidden
final state mission and how do you model
the temporal contraction and does that
matter in this particular application we
explore this question by using
artificial neural network to observe a
larger contracts window for each hidden
state in particular the feature vectors
are observed in context window and then
the output of the neural networks at the
posterior switch are transformed and
then fed into a dynamic basic model in
particular a hidden Markov model so the
this this is also learning from the
speech recognition community but it's
not always working in speech recognition
because I think people having these
lessons I'm saying when the task is of
low SNR and also when the models are
relatively context independent
then this tandem approach usually would
give you more pronounced improvement and
these two assumptions do stand true for
our application because the SNR is
indeed blow and also the models are less
context dependent because we don't
really know whether this is there's no
nothing like in the tri phone speaking
speech models where you have a very
rigidly defined and context so basically
we take a larger window of these
frame-based features and take the output
of the neural network transform and use
that as a input to the HMMs another
question is is the temporal structure
very important or not so because up to
now we use the HMMs to model the events
in particular the elements are of the
topology of left to right so so what we
do want the different state sequence to
capture the temporal structure within
each event segment proposed however
there there there's an alternative way
to look at these audio segments the
audio segments they vary england's but
in a sense they are all a a set of local
frame-based features so looking at an
audio segment whatever lens it is is
looking at a joint distribution of all
these frame-based feature vectors um so
the way that we did here was did also
have successful speaker i dealing
language ID so this the idea here is to
look at the audio segment as a set of
these local descriptors and then we
would approximate this joint
distribution using a gaussian mixture
model and then the parameters of the
gaussian mixture model would be used to
construct a super vector which becomes
this uniform Lenz vector representation
for the audio segment that varies in
men's and once we have this vector
representation it can be shown that this
vector representation put into a linear
kernel actually approximates the care of
divergence picturing the different audio
segments
and the kernel can be used in whatever
classifier of your choice so in
particular in particular the GM super
vector is is the normalized stacked mean
vectors from the different components
and it can be shown that the care of
divergence between the future
distributions can be approximated by the
Euclidean distance which is why we can
use a linear kernel and there there are
some assumptions behind these being true
in particular the when we need the
different Gaussian mixture models to be
obtained by adapting from a global model
so so the scenario here is that will
train a UV a more global model using
these frame-based feature vectors from
all audio segments that we have
available in training regardless of
their categorical labels and then we'll
adapt this global model into each
different audio segment so it's it's
adapting to the each different audio
segments instead of adapting to each
category so in the end you have one
gaussian mixture model for one audio
segment so we're using this gaussian
mixture model as the approximation to
the joint distribution of all local
descriptors within one segment the
segment here we're talking about usually
varies from one second to ten seconds it
could sometimes be be shorter depending
on the particular events like footsteps
usually are pretty low but door slammers
shudder and keygen goer not very long as
well presentation really happy
yeah so for for dap tation we're doing
map adaptation in this experiment and
with some country good price yeah
roughly the more data you have from each
segment the better the adaptation will
be so as you may have noticed a 44 this
approach we actually do need some
predefined boundaries so the way that we
get around this is to have the first
parts being the hmm based Viterbi
decoding and then use the hypothesis the
boundaries which the hypothesize the
boundaries will be able to approximate
the joint distributions here so in the
end we'll have mapped decoding which is
Viterbi decoding of veterans and then
which the hypothesis boundaries and
event labels or do confidence restoring
based on the classification result or
out of the GMM super vectors and in the
end when we combining the two hypotheses
and it also gives opens this possibility
to refine output result according to the
particular metric of your problem so in
this case the ad metrocard mentioned so
that 80 metric is basically the F score
returning the hypothesized event
sequence and the ground truth event
sequence so they'll give you something
complementary to what map decoding finds
you a very quick go over of some of the
results here so this this was on the
clear 2007 acoustic event detection data
there were 12 general meeting room
non-speech event such as keyboard typing
coffin chair moving so basically in
could improve the baseline result which
is the hmm based results that we
submitted to the evaluation by having a
better contacts temporal context
modeling so the tendon model and also as
222 harnish this complementary
information from a JMM super vector
model in the restoring increase carving
face here so this is saying even if we
don't have this very rigid tempo
structure captured by the hidden state
sequence there is at least some
complimentary information are coming
from looking at audio segments in a
different way and and the two things are
kind of additive each other that could
further improve your result so then I
talked about our experiences in
categorization and localization of video
events free admission is working on the
features the features here yeah I didn't
talk about features here but if you say
if we need some result tomorrow I just
recommend using mfcc LP LP the the
particular features that we used was
kind of a engineer toward this task in
particular we bring together mfcc VLPs
and filter banks with different
parameters so build a pool of kind of
well engineered speech features and then
we select some of the and weedy
correlate these features and selects a
subset of the features out of the pool
according to some boosting based methods
or according to the base error for
individual features yeah zero crossing
we haven't used that we have other
participants actually use that yeah we
haven't explored this in particular and
and frankly I have to say the reason
that we performed better than the other
participants it's we don't have proof
saying that it's on the feature side
whether we're doing better or not we
believe it's more on the modeling site
that we're doing everything right and in
a reasonable way that's give us an
advantage yeah the way we
yeah or we we kind of derived features
out of the pool that consists of em
FCC's filter banks and therapies the
major motivations that we want to
leverage on what the community has
accumulated over the decades and we
believe these features are are are the
best choice if you have a limited time
so your multi to remodel and arrive
another way to sing be able to have a
Moche skill prosecute features so yeah
we gotta you still try it I guess we
haven't explicitly tried in that regard
I think the only way to say that we
might have some kind of multiscale
temporal thing happening here is in the
first parts the hmm has this neural
network to observe a larger context or
in wiring restoring face we didn't we
just use the local frame based features
but it's complimentary in different ways
in one way is that it does not have this
rigid hidden state sequence and also as
I said the GMC directors did observe
directly the frame based features not
with this wide contacts with removal so
I talked about categorization
localization video events this is sense
it around improved image and video
representation called Gaussian I vector
representation but as we as we go on I
think this audience will find a lot of
these things very similar to what we
just saw from the gym and super vector
because it's just we are actually
inspired by what's happening in the
speech and audio models and to see
whether we can look at image and videos
in a similar way so in particular the
Gaussian is the vector representation is
our attempt to say can we model images
and videos without explicitly worrying
about segmentation or the particular
object detection within that image I'm
saying so
the Gaussian X vector representation
adapts a set of Gaussian mixtures
according to the set of HBase
descriptors in an image of video clip
and the adaptation will be regularized
by a global gaussian mixture model and
also the final linear kernel will be
improved by was in class covariance
normalization and because of the success
that we had in doing works like
categorization within and regression and
we're thinking what would be a
reasonable way to apply this
representation for object localization
so in the end we adopt an efficient
branch and bound search scheme and this
could be potentially used identify
regions of interest in the video
corresponding to different events so one
of the major problems in computer vision
probably in any of the machine learning
problems is that you want to find the
correspondence between a data set so if
we're looking at different phases here
we could easily see that if you want to
compare the different phases you
probably want to compare I see eyes in
the mouth of your mouse but if you look
at some more realistic images like a
bedroom image or a broadcast news image
even if we see the bedrooms probably but
both have a bad in sight but it's less
apparent what kind of particular
correspondence we should find between
the two images and if you like look at
the video the broadcast news video even
if this event is categorized as car
entering we don't necessarily see a very
complete car in the image so that makes
any efforts based on detecting a
particular car very challenging and if
doable at all so visual cues for
real-world events they present extra
challenges for correspondence compared
to some other tasks like face processing
so the way that we look at image and
video modeling is to look at them as a
set of local patch descriptors a patch
is a very small region in the image in
original spatial domain so there are two
ways two major ways that people have
used to extract patches right
the first way is that you would do a 2d
sliding window called called a patches
extracted from a dense pixel grid and
and then firm for each patch you have
some descriptor based on that particular
patch another way to is to have some
kind of low level detectors for example
a sip detector would actually find
regions where there is contrast or edge
basically something hopefully bear those
information but in the end of the day
you all get a set of local descriptors
anyways so the image or the video clip
becomes a set of local descriptors the
most popular way to to deal with this
set of local descriptors it's called a
histogram of keywords basically you have
k-means clustering to establish a
codebook and then the histogram of the
counts for different code books code
code book entries becomes the
information that you carry for that
image so a very complex in for image
like this or a video clip like like this
or become a histogram in the end there's
large quantization errors and lots of
discriminability so we're trying to see
what can we do to improve beyond that oh
and I have to mention that there is
improvement over the histogram of
keywords itself that the way I present
here is kind of simplified version of
different things the way that we address
this problem is that we still start from
the set of local descriptors in the
original feature space and then same as
in audio the way the information that we
need from the image or video clip is
basically the Joint Distribution of all
these local descriptors so to be able to
approximate this joint distribution and
hopefully be robust annoys and we'll use
a gaussian mixture model to fit this
local descriptor example and then in the
end you'll have the the gaussian mixture
model that approximates the joint
exhibition here and then looking at
different images it's nothing but
King ad it's letting bit different from
looking at the different Gaussian
mixture models each corresponding to one
image and in particular you take this
normalized means of the Gaussian
components to form a super vector each
corresponding to one image or video clip
yeah so you need to have a global model
set so that you're the KO divergence can
take this simple form adapt to each
image or each video clip so we use this
for different kinds of scenarios one is
for each image you have a set of local
descriptors the other is for video clip
classification you basically have a set
of local descriptions extracted from all
the images avoiding that video clip but
we haven't worried about the temporal
structure of the different images
sequence within the video clip so yeah
so we have a local a global model that
the trend using local descriptors from
all kinds of images and videos available
to us regardless of their categories and
also the Adept adaptation is done using
local descriptors extracted from one
image or one video clip and adaptation
can be done with the conjugate prior
just to help establish this
correspondence with the original global
models and it can be shown that the
distance between the two images or video
clips can be characterized by the
approximated care divergence and in
particular you could see if you write
this stack to me normalizing a proper
way the hell divergence can be
approximated by the Euclidean distance
so that so the kernel function here
takes an interesting form its linear but
each of these five here is actually
usually a very high dimension so in our
experiments we would easily take 500
rousing components for broadcast news
video and maybe for simpler data said
you could take em smaller
number of gaussian components because if
because it's linear so it's less a
problem computationally to wrap up on
this part so the gaza nized vector
representation has a cup of advantages
compared to the original histogram of
keywords representation first the
assignment into the different keyword is
it is replaced by a soft assignment to
the different gaussian components
according to their posterior and then we
could leverage them had an odious
distance instead of a Euclidean distance
although for this representation the
Mahalanobis distance can be written as a
Euclidean distance if you have this
normalized properly and also the
multiple other studies are taking into
consideration in particular compared to
only the counts which is the zero other
statistics we can also use the adaptive
means and also take into consideration
the covariance matrices so a way to
visualize this is in place of the very
simplistic histogram of keywords
representation that the gaussian eyes
director representation would not only
establish the correspondence through the
different gaussian components as the
hubs in in the 2d visualization but also
according to how well all these local
descriptors are adapted into these
different nodes and what their
distribution is around the different
modes so a kind of a diversion from here
is that the the the way that we do this
is is saying we don't want to establish
any hard segmentation because it's very
hard for a realistic data but we were
basically leveraging only the Gaussian
components to give us that kind of
correspondence but if what kind of data
that is very structured like a human
face can we use something beyond the
mixture of gaussians to set up this
correspondence the answer is yes one way
to do this is one most straightforward
way to do this I was
is to use a hidden Markov model and for
example we tried face images if you take
a hidden Markov model even if a very
simple left to right hidden Markov model
if you arrange your local patch
descriptors in ask inline style such
that you would observe first the ice and
then the nose and then the mouse then a
very simple lefty right is hmm would
give you some additional performance
improvement because the hidden states
here kind of capture the temporal
structure that's very structured with
face images and this is not usually true
for broadcast news or general video but
for faces they're true another way to
look at why the Gaussian inspector
representation had very good practical
performances is that if if we do some
approximation and look at the feature in
such a way first we can calculate the
posterior of an observed patch coming
from the case mixture and then we can
randomly distribute the observed patch
into M Gaussian components or classes by
a multinomial trial according to the
posterior probability so in the real
world we are doing adaptation so it's
kind of a weighted summation but if you
look at as a multinomial trial then you
would be able to write out the equations
and see that the final super vector
actually observe a standard normal
distribution so that this has a benefit
because a lot of the later processing
for computer vision usually take this as
a assumption for example if we people
need to do PCA to reduce dimension
people need to calculate distance in the
Euclidean this as a Euclidean distance
all those processes are assuming that
the feature vector lives in lives in in
the Euclidean space so this
representations partially to satisfy
that assumption so we believe this might
be the reason why it will give you a
performance boost so up to now we have
used no categorical supervision for
deriving these representations
of course you can use the kernels in an
SVM then introduce the supervision but
before that we would like to do
something else to leverage the
categorical labels that are so expensive
to obtaining the first place in
particular we'd use with in class
covariance normalization to identify a
subspace for the Colonel's that has
maximum inter image or inter video
distances within the same categories so
basically this term is here is
calculating the distance between
different images if they are coming from
the same category and then and in the
end you get this covariance of these the
caverns that contributed from all these
pairs that come from the same category
the refined Gaussian noise vector
colonel would suppress this undesired
subspace because it tells us nothing
about the target category labels so in
particular can suppress that subspace by
subtracting it from the original
identical identical caverns Colonel
Colonel matrix here so we're comparing
this with the the dense state of art a
paper working working on a video event
categorization retrieval so this is a
paper that was given the best
performance for this particular task but
it was also a very representative way of
how the computer vision community looks
at these problems so the particular wait
here is that they are dividing the video
clip into sub clips in a hierarchy so
you have maybe you have so this is one
video clip and the other is another one
so the essential problem is how do we
characterize the distance between the
two video clips so the way many people
look at this is that I want to find a
correspondence between the two video
clips so I want to see which frame
corresponds to which frame this is
temporally but potentially you could
also do which local descriptor
corresponds to another
descriptor I'm spatially nobody buddy
that that's the same idea so in
particular you could establish a kind of
hierarchy to look at this video clip at
different temporal resolutions and then
you try to find pairs between the the
the grids in the different video clips
to establish this correspondence and
based on some optimization and then once
you establish that correspondence
hopefully when you calculate the
distance between the two video video
clips you your calculation is to compare
apples apple and pear whisperer however
we're showing that even if you don't
have that explicit step to do this
computation you could also get
reasonable and even better result using
something like the Garcia next vector
representation so in particular we're
comparing we're using the Gaussian X
vector representation which with
different classifiers we could show with
even with the nearest neighbor
classifier it's actually performing
pretty well compared with in the ta ta
p.m. approach people actually use the
support vector machine so if we combine
the Gaussian white Gaussian noise vector
representation with the support vector
machine that gives you an even more
pronounced improvement and also we could
get benefits by I'm taking with in class
government's normalization to refine the
colonel in this super vector space
another
this is a TTA p.m. without the
temporally allowing the Permian mansion
it's a separate thing because we we
actually didn't worry about the explicit
alignment between the images and we
believe they actually did find the
alignment sometimes makes sense but not
always so I think the idea here is not
to say we don't want to any alignment in
the end but we want to say if the
alignment very hard to do can we do
something reasonable such that even if
we don't do alignment we can perform
comparable II the answer seems to be we
could perform even better on this
particular problem so that's one of the
reasons we think this this is a a result
that we're very excited about and we we
prove this similar findings on different
applications as far as envisioned that
they inform you have an integrated your
system no so do you think you one day
incubator on top of your results you can
get better this yeah or or you already
have used some of that concert yeah we
could have already honey some of these
information this is a similar problem
like if you do do it in our way only
using the GM or using a multi-state hmm
do you think the motive hmm always would
be better than the single-stage mm
leonsis not maybe not always so for face
processing where there's a very strict
temporal structure and this temporal
structure is easy to capture using a
left to right you can capture a part of
it if that's the case then then probably
a more complicated model would actually
do you good but for broadcast news um
because the from their experiences that
the fount correspondents are not always
what they intended so so we're not sure
maybe a version of that combining with
ours there is always a chance to improve
but the idea of doing segmentation in
the first place sometimes could could be
a dangerous one to do it's just like do
you always want to do speech recognition
by kind of doing phone sequence
recognition first and then try to get
that into whole word sequence it's a
similar philosophy but we did we did use
some of the other alignment masses that
are popular with the computer vision
community for example they would do a
hierarchical pyramid over the spatial
domain and try to take some assumptions
for example the left right the left
right corner probably also corresponds
to left or cornering and as a image
things like that and in some
applications we actually do find
improvement for for that
no this foot yeah yeah effort for this
one yes yep but this one we're
essentially assigning labels to each
video clips yes yes yeah exactly yes so
we do have a side benefit which is
because we look at this image and video
as a set of local descriptors so it's
less prone to occlusion so even if you
include if even if you only use twenty
percent of the local descriptors your
performance don't drop much but there is
a warning here because this twenty
percent is is fairly randomly sampled so
so so if you very carefully include all
those important local descriptors then
then they probably won't work as well
but just as a note here if we randomly
sample twenty percent of the local
descriptives the result will be pretty
much intact yeah in this one were using
a feudal using
not for this one no we used some other
features for other tasks but the idea of
this modeling back-end is similar so we
want to see can we use because it gave
us a lot of advantages in doing
categorization retrieval but all these
things are talking about the global
information based on the whole images so
can we do something similar for
localization which define the particular
object within an image and tell how
large they are so we adopt a
branch-and-bound scheme that has been
proposed by Lampard to allow efficient
object localization that achieves global
optimum with n square instead of n force
and also this scheme has been successful
I applied for his the one of keywords so
that gave us a way to preliminary
compare with what other people have done
using similar approaches so in
particular the branch advanced scheme
regardless of the OD detailed nuances
here the basic idea is that you want to
search all these ends and power to the
four rectangles but not one by one you
want to serve out sets of them if they
if they have a very good bound to tell
you what the upper bound for that
particular rectangle set is and if the
bound is not is worse than the band of
another set then you can always start
with the set with the highest abound and
then if the bound is good enough then
you you won't miss the the target
rectangle that you are hunting after in
particular you would initialize a NP
empty queue of the rectangle sets and
initialize this a rectangle set to be
all the rectangles so if we characterize
this is top button left and right the
set are initialized as all rectangles
are having the the top button and left
right to be complete scale for for each
of these dimensions
and then we would obtain two sets by
splitting the parameter space along the
largest of the four dimensions then you
will push these two rectangle sets into
the queue with their respective quality
bound which we'll talk about in a minute
and then and then we'll update our by
saying we'll look at the set with the
highest quality bound in the end that
the set would the shrink and shrink and
in the end it will become only when one
rectangle that's the one that we are
trying to find so so in order to
introduce the quality bound will first
talk about the quality function here
which is informing the confidence of the
evaluated sub area being the target
object so we're actually using the
output of the binary SVM in just in a
standard format so the bound should
satisfy two conditions it'll be larger
than any of the quality functions
evaluated at any of the member
rectangles and also if the set becomes
one member only then the balance should
be equal to the quality function
evaluated on that single member so you
can see first we can see on the the
quality function can be rewritten with
approximations as a is the summation of
some of the contributions from each
local descriptor so in particularly
define this / feature vector
contribution here so in the end we'll
know this if you are to evaluate a
particular rectangle that's nothing more
than evaluating the summation of the
contributions coming from all the member
patches within that sub area so if we
can written it in this linear format
then the quality bound can be written as
the summation of the positive local
contributions from the largest rectangle
plus the summation of the negative
contributions from the smallest
rectangle so if it's so this this one is
to a proper is to evaluate the quality
bound for a rectangle
that's essentially all these positives
coming from the largest member and all
the negatives coming from the smallest
member and and they'll be easy to verify
this satisfies the two conditions that
we just set forth Jim volumes over every
factor whether it's official point if
you like to read for class increase
telescope missed opportunities
we so this this is so you're talking
about how this / featured contribution
is calculated for facebook page
because you already more than Jimmy I'm
anyways you start issuing an opt-in
fashion they do that because they don't
want that they don't listen to English
muffin but you already already use
channel tamales you could computer back
would switch for each thousand columns a
few fish fish burger right yeah we use
the Gaussian mixture models to
approximate one distributions for one
image in one video clip but there is no
class information yeah there's no class
information here and of course you could
say why don't we do classification based
on classification of each local
descriptor but i'm pretty sure that will
not work because a single local
descriptor is very noisy so if you want
to do classification based on that then
it's usually not working as well so so
we are using the gaussian mixture model
to approximate all this journey with
distribution within one image and to
hope this smooth distribution modeling
can intentionally and suppress that some
of the noise is coming from the local
descriptors so that's why but if you
look at this / feature vector
contribution here rather that's what
what I was about to say is that the
calculation of all these things are
essentially the same as calculating the
adaptation of a global model into this
particular image with all the local
descriptors so so because the perfect
vector contribution it seems you need to
do this for all the local descriptives
but that's the same thing as doing that
adaptation where you already sum up the
adaptations of each feature vector
according to their posteriors two
different gaussian components so
computationally it's very similar to
getting the set of the complete set of
perfume vector contribution is
computationally similar to doing the
adaptation for the whole image just
because you could written it as in
approximated as a linear way
in the previous lien people that are
producing we are talking about the given
condition right and just based on the
compression between video clips to
another view clips yeah so it seems not
very scalable if you have a lot of whom
they both
50 events you have to compete with all
the different events oh so reduce the
comparison so once we get this Gaussian
noise vector in place then then we're
basically just calculate the kernel
matrix yeah you're basically you have a
multi class yeah that's the same ideas
if you have multi class svm for
classification of multiple categories
right all the clips yeah you need to
compete with each of the training ones
yes all right inside you really don't
follow any event your model event
leading the kernel space yes increase
tree yeah yeah only with the colonel
spacey remodel the events so for that we
I have
car entering event and i have 100 video
clips for kind okay I trivia so you have
to compete with the awesome yes that's
right but in this localization party
seems you are me differently you more
localization you're actually doing the
same so for localization one thing that
I I probably should have emphasizes it's
basically a based on the two class
classification problem right it's either
the foreground the target or is the
background so when you have you still
you say you have 500 positive training
tokens foreground and then you have 500
negative background images or and then
so so what your training this a binary
class svm and then interesting time you
still have to calculate the colonel you
have to evaluate this kernel with using
the one test vector with all this rain a
mother deserves poverty likelihood of
institute which
each event right not really listen whoa
that is some other says it but that's
confusing part yeah it does not model
that I think would have feature Berkeley
respect your crops right it a lot 1 it
says how you do do so the only
difference featuring in this regard is a
binary SVM vs and multi classes so so
you calculate the you calculate the
kernel matrix and then it's it's the
training of the svn the deals with this
categorical supervision so you're always
getting so the only thing that we change
here is how do you calculate the
distance between two images yeah so you
are still looking at this kernel matrix
which is always looking at two
individual images one coming from
training and one coming from the testing
and the other training you have all the
label the reacts yeah so southern US vm
solo yeah yeah then is the way where the
supervision comes to do that's really
where you soap you use do possible data
would have beautiful and obvious yeah
okay so the fish vectors that are
located
full an object yeah the rest of physics
yeah minor crossfire yeah so that that's
all sort of you don't really need it
here separate the classes you just do do
the same / even for a class or it done
what many like a four or so are entering
you have one the train svm another type
of event so the way that we did
practically is that we we we get this
one simple vector this vector
representation for one image right so
for each let's first talk about the
video event categorization problem so we
have one vector for an image and then we
also know the label for that vector then
we throw this into a multi-class svm
training program so for localization we
have different images some of these are
target some of these are the background
and each of them will be converted into
a vector right and then we throw this
into binary swim but when you saw it
into the binary svm training you
basically throw the kernel matrix e
right yeah i'm using that you
classifiers not just just it's not just
to compare I sure the class by itself is
supervised so let's assess p.m. so this
is the different from what you do
it was a humidity of the categorisation
firm right and that experiment the way
you took us patient even from so for
localization that the core is the binary
classifier but but for localization the
problem is that you have to do binary
classification for many hypotheses
rectangles right yeah so the way that it
looks different here is just because you
organize it in this linear summation so
that you can reuse a lot of computation
and also you could you could down this
subset of hypotheses rectangles and then
throw them away if they're if they are
bound is better
but but at the course it's actually a
binary classification is to tell whether
this sub area is the foreground or
background so in that sense it's the
same as the video technology we're
suppose
okay yeah he hears some some examples of
how things look for localization so
basically you would identify the areas
correct if you have collected this local
positive red areas and less of these
negative blue areas and and sometimes it
goes round because the the red areas are
not as clustered together as we want or
or sometimes we count it as a run
detection when you you combine two cars
into one model so we compared with we
compare this with a similar work using
the histogram of keywords based on this
search and down scheme so it's
consistently improving beyond the
histogram of keywords and we can also
see I'm doing with in class
normalization can also further improve
the result where all these ends are
meaning the coding class governance
novelization okay so I quickly goes
through the third part which is
relatively short anyways so this part is
trying to say acoustic even detection is
very hard and even if we did reasonably
well the performance is far from usable
from a practical perspective so where to
so people are trying to look at can we
engage video to help just as the way
that we engage lips to help speech
recognition so for for the previous work
people have proposed a detection by
classification system and in a system
and use a lot of extra information
including audio spatial localization
multi-person tracking motion analysis
face recognition object detection the
drawback is that training Lee all these
ad hoc visual detectors are very
expensive and we're trying to see can we
go around this and do something
reasonable such that the performance is
comparable at least
so what we the way we look at this is
that these all these non-speech
audio/video events are mostly related to
motion so we're using visual features
based on optical flow and then we are
summarizing all these optical flow
firings using an overlapping spatial
pyramid histogram so basically we're
looking at a complete image and
calculate a histogram of the local
optical flow firing a magnitude and also
we look at this two-by-two grid and then
extract for histograms and then we look
at this three by one grid and look at
extract the three histograms and then we
stack all these histograms together and
do the correlation and use that as a
featured video feature vector for each
frame and that goes together with the
mfcc or something like that for the
audio stream so to combine these we use
the multi stream uhmm and coupled hmm in
particular with the couple hmm there's a
lot of hassle to initialize such that
the output pdfs becomes reasonable so
the way we tried the two different
schemes one way to initialize using a
state synchronized multi stream hmm pair
another way to initialize it using pairs
of audio only and video only instrument
yeah so the couple hmm it's basically a
couple of hmm is saying the state you
know in a multi stream hmm the the audio
state sequence and the video state
sequence with the progress at the same
pace so the first audio state goes to
the second at the same same time the
video goes to the second in the couple
hmm they can go a synchronized from the
perspective of the state sequence so
maybe the audio state is already
progression into the second one while
the video state is still residing in the
first one but actually you could look at
a couple extra room as a hmm with most
states but the equivalent hmm have more
states because each of the states in
equivalent hmm is defined
both the audio state variable and the
video state variable in the capo hmm so
in our experiment we're actually
allowing state asynchrony up to one
state so that you don't really grow this
topology into a huge huge structure so
in the end it's it's about how do you
initialize the output PDFs of the couple
determine or its equivalent hmmm so so
when I'm saying we initialize using
multi stream instruments basically
initializing assuming that audio and
video states should always be
synchronized on the state level and then
we would combine the PDF from the first
audio state with the first video state
and also we have another state that's
combining the first audio PDF with the
second video pedia so in that case you
construct this equivalent at this hmm
equivalent to the capital hmm another
way to do this is to initialize using
all the only hmm video only hmm and then
put their states together and once we
put together this equivalent this couple
hmm equivalent hmm then we can do we
estimated based on the new apology that
tends to converge is easier than if you
directly train on a coverage and pretty
much always fails and most of the states
never get reversed so the answer is in
terms of can we get performance similar
to doing all these lower level detectors
itself absolutely yes so we could
actually do better than their approach
the benefits come from of course
multiple places first if you use the
dynamic person that model to do with her
by decoding there gives the advantage
and also when you do when you when you
characterize the video using this
generalizable feature that sometimes may
even give you advantage then to use the
very localized low level detector
another thing is that however the two
ways to initialize the HM actually turns
out to be not very significantly
different but you
as a warning is that it is important to
initialize them reasonably but which one
doesn't seems to make much difference
here okay I think I need to wrap up here
so it's basically i talked about audio
event modeling a lot of lessons from
speech recognition and video clip
modeling where we want to say can we can
we do these jobs reasonably without
going all these very painstaking
segmentation the answers yes and in many
cases we actually do better and then we
could improve the acoustic event
detection by using audio visual multi
multi modality all the way thank you
it's the picture of the incomplete group
I maybe you would recognize a couple
faces who was here on this campus for a
while and i have a few very quick shots
but i think we're going over time try
should i take five more minutes or try
stuff okay some other projects that so
just because this is a very
interdisciplinary group that the speech
go vent video group work very closely
together and i also had experience
working with phonology who are
interested to see whether a phonological
theory works in speech recognition setup
or can we devise a computation model
according to this theory so that gives
me exposure to a cup of different
projects that might be related to
something happening here for example we
worked on a pronunciation modeling which
basically following the articulatory
phenomenology theory so according to
this theory a word as a word is
pronounced as this word because there's
a unique set of gestural tagged targets
behind it define on different tracks
variables and and when the word is
articulated with something else or the
speak rate changes there's a speech
reduction this set of gestural targets
are still there they are just arranged
in different ways they shift along time
but the the targets are still there but
because they overlap with each
in different ways so their service form
change so that's their theory and we're
trying to build a model according to
this theory so the way that I answer
this question is if we define the the
gestural targets at a local time frame
as a vector then this 2d representation
just becomes a vector sequence problem
so we will say a gestural score as a 2d
dimension here defined on track
variables in time could be approximated
as a sequence of jestro pattern vectors
each vector defined on the construction
targets at this local time so once we
have this formulation we want to see can
we do speech observation to vector just
repair the vector sequence thus to the
to the gesture score therefore two words
so the gestural kind of vector would
encode instantaneous patterns of gesture
activations across all tracked variables
in the gesture score given a particular
time and the gestural score approximated
as a sequence of gestural patent vectors
is the example of gestural activations
which is basically the approximated
gestural pano vector sequence and of
course at each step we could introduce
some confidence score the likelihoods
the the interesting part is actually on
the gesture score to word part where
we'd use the gene that gestural tiny
model which was originally developed for
articulatory phonology to generate one
canonical gestural score for different
work this is like the canonical
pronunciation for this word so the words
will be distinguishable according to the
gesture scores in the sense that they
are distinguishable according to this
example of gestural targets behind them
but they're not distinguishable
according to the particular timings
because when a word is pronounced by
different people in different contexts
the timings tend to change according to
articulate articulate or phonology so
the computation model that we device
according to this theory is that we have
a finite
mission emitting just your pattern
vector sequences so you can imagine each
part in this finite state machine
actually is emitting a gesture pattern
vector sequence which is essentially a
gesture skull with particular timing so
if we look at the word the here that
these are the different track variables
so this the always have these four
gestural activation targets but they
could be arranged in different timings
and we want to summarize all this into a
finite state machine through some
recursive process and once we have this
finite state machine so this machine is
basically the pronunciation of this
single word and once we have this
mission will be able to do word
recognition by composing a lattice with
a pronunciation model which is roughly
the union of this all these different
word pronunciations looking at acoustic
viola fishing or by
we actually look at the canonical speech
gesture so we we have this gesture
timing model which could generate one of
this 2d representation for each word and
then we're saying the pronunciations
allowed are basically all the different
possible shiftings of all these gestural
targets so we're building this
recursively by saying looking at the
canonical one let's say the example of
the gestural targets we have and then at
each time frame we're proposing possible
combinations of them and then weighted
by some some kind of quality measures to
to measure whether this combination is
possible or not from from the training
data of from their theory so so at each
so each time we're doing a interstate
transition it's it's like changing from
a particular local gestural target
combination into a next one and each
self transition is saying we'll stay in
this particular configuration for
another time slot so we're building this
recursively as building a tree and then
in the end you can optimize this finite
state machine by weight pushing and
everything but once you get is finite
state machine you could use the open
source finite state machine tool boxes
to optimize and construct the dictionary
but this is still at a very early stage
it's not we don't have any evidence to
say this works better than the
conventional approaches so it's more
like interdisciplinary exploration with
the phone ologist
set up detectors oh the targets yeah
Suze so the way that the partner I
worked on was to devise how these things
all put together we have collaborators
enhancing slabs they were working on how
do you recover this underlining 2d
representation from the speech surface
form so so they have actually a series
of works working on that but I think
it's probably beyond what I can talk
about yeah another another thing is we
had we did some some kind of speech
retrieval for unknown language for a
multimedia evaluation where the the
basic but basic idea is that you build
indexes for each data set a database
entry using us summarize each data data
entry as a lattice and then convert that
into a finite state machine based index
term so that term is basically allowing
transitions from the beginning in too
many of the internal notes instead of
requiring a complete traversing of the
one passing the lattice so when you
introducing these extra transitions from
the beginning to the different nodes you
would associate with that was something
like a forward probability or backward
probability so that part we're actually
just following the bell labs approach
before and the reason of doing it that
way is I was given three weeks to build
this system so i want to devise
something that requires less tuning so
i'm using a finite state machine was was
a reasonable way to do this and and the
tuning could mostly be done using
standard optimization methods for a no
speech we are talking about looking at
train model training with different
languages but none of which is the
testing language that you retrieve from
so the idea here is that you would want
to have models that are hopefully
language independent so the way that we
address this is to cluster all this
language dependent
atomic models and then the clustering
based on their pairwise distances and
then a clustering result would hope the
cluster result will hopefully capture
information that is shared across the
different training languages but not
language specific and hopefully that
length that information is Moe
transferable to a brand-new never seen
language at the testing yeah oh the last
one was actually done with Microsoft the
problem was to convert from speech to
lips we had originally a baseline with
HTS based since this model you build one
trifon visual model for each phone and
then you can synthesize the lips from
the trifling sequence which is known
before so the question here is can you
engage audio to improve and second can
you do lips without knowing the ground
truth song sequence which usually can be
hard to get the answer are yes to both
questions you want to engage the audio
so that you can engage the audios in the
maximum likelihood estimation of the
video observation which which will be
which would improve beyond this visual
only synthesis and the diagram shown
here is more on the conversion side
where we don't have this ground choose
film sequence at all the idea here is
that if we are going from speech to lips
it looks like it's not always necessary
to jump this a huge semantic gap to find
the underlining speech content and it
may be easier to not going to the speech
content just because how hard it is so
the way that we address this is to use
the audiovisual joint gaussian mixture
model and then we'll select the
optimized modernity wait according to a
development set and then on the other
hand we want to find the visual sequence
that best mimic the ground troops video
sequence the maximum likelihood is a
good criteria to work with but it's not
necessarily in line with the the target
metric which is the human
a human conception is very hard to do so
when we making the human perception
using meet the mean square error of the
synthesized the trajectories so that
will use they'll be able to refine the
visual graduation model that's its kind
of extension to the minimum generation
arrow that the Microsoft has worked on
speech synthesis now this was in a
conversion setup yeah that's all I have
today thank you